c'était vraiment une zone de pirates et
de bandits et là on n'en mène pas large
donc on est on est blanc dans un endroit
où on nous identifie tout de suite on
voit très bien qu'on n'est pas du cru et
on nous regarde bizarrement du coin de
l'oeil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tous
on m'avait donné pour mission de rentrer
dans un petit village frontière dans
lequel il y avait énormément de trafic
et il n'y avait aucun membre du service
qui était rentré dans cette zone avant
aucun journaliste c'était une zone de
non-droit trouver la bonne personne qui
va vous amener qui va vous ouvrir les
portes et vous amener dans une zone de
non droit à une zone interdite
normalement pour un occidental
c'est toute la difficulté de l'exercice
et c'est donc évidemment un travail qui
se fait en amont et quand vous créez
votre légende votre fausse identité et
bien évidemment faut la penser en ayant
une idée ça en arrière de la tête il ya
ce je veux rencontrer de tels types de
personnes qui va pouvoir me permettre
d'ouvrir la porte
ces moments là la tension est à son
maximum on réfléchit à 10 milles à
l'heure on pense à on pense à collecter
renseignements et imprimer la rétine de
tout ce qu'on voit à noter des plaques
d'immatriculation si on nous passe un
téléphone entre les mains on essaie de
récupérer les numéros de téléphone et en
même temps on pense à sa propre sécurité
et on regarde si les gens nous regardent
bizarrement ou non si on est suivie si
si les gens autour de nous réagit d'une
manière qui n'est pas normal s'il nous
arrive quelque chose il ya qu à kano a
trouvé la solution sans que ça on est on
est foutu c'est toute la difficulté de
ce type de mission aux clandestins
c'est qu'on est isolé si c'est les
choses se passent mal on fera rien pour
vous c'est à vous trouver la solution
c'est sûr que une série comme le bureau
des légendes donne un aspect le plus
réaliste possible sur la véritable vie
des agents secrets de la dgse
c'est par exemple les mêmes décors tout
a été recréée à l'identique qu'on ait
les mêmes bureaux les mêmes fonds
d'écran sur les ordinateurs les mêmes
logo les mêmes décors des couloirs des
bureaux des agents donc ça c'est à côté
très réaliste mais ensuite ça reste
quand même une fiction est donc en gros
titre est donc il ya beaucoup de mes
aventures des chausse-trappes de
d'arrestation un petit peu rocambolesque
donc la vie la vie d'un agent secret et
elle n'est pas comme dans le bureau de
légende et notamment on passe beaucoup
plus de temps à écrire sur son
ordinateur que ce qui est montré dans la
série je me suis jamais sentie en danger
de mort il faut savoir qu'un agent
souvent de la dgse il va travailler dans
une ville et ceux qui prennent le risque
finalement c'est l'heure c'est la source
moi quand je rencontre un terroriste
s'est infiltré ou quelqu'un qui
travaille à jaca en zone état islamique
dans le nord de la syrie c'est lui qui
prend les risques
je vais lui donner des consignes
récupérer tout ce qui a pu récupérer
mais c'est lui ensuite qui doit repartir
repasser la frontière refaire la route
et travailler à nouveau en plein coeur
de l'état islamique
donc c'est eux qui ont des choses à
raconter un petit peu sur les risques
qu'ils prennent l'agent secret bien
souvent lui il se contente de deux
pilotés à distance sa source malgré tous
ces gens là restent dangereux cette
source elle peut être retourné elle peut
être détecté par l'état islamique et
ensuite je lui dise bon ok tu vas tu
équipé d'une ceinture explosive où tu
vas t'on officier traitant tu vas tu vas
te le payer ces gens là qu'ils
travaillent dans des zones extrêmement
sensible au coeur de l'état islamique
est bien quand on les reçoit dans le
local de contacts qui sont
systématiquement fouillés on se rappelle
d'un l'attentât de khost en afghanistan
où il ya une source jordanienne qui se
retournait contre ces officiers
traitants
c'est la cia il s'est fait explosé il ya
eu 17 morts je suis assez surpris de
constater qu'une fois qu'on débranche le
fil du stress de la dren aliens de de la
niaque de ses missions qui est qui qui
nous pousse et bien finalement on prend
un petit peu de recul et on s'aperçoit
de tout ce qu'on a tous les sacrifices
qu'on a fait pour cette carrière et
notamment pas de vie sociale pato d'amis
une vie sauve une vie familiale
restreint parce qu'on peut pas raconter
ce qu'on fait et bien finalement quand
on débranche et qu'on arrête on se dit
tiens maintenant je peux arriver à
parler avoir des amis à qui je peux
raconter ce que je fais et c'est quand
même assez agréable également